sur l'écran d'information l'audience en
correctionnelle est encore affiché il
est 10 heures passées et pourtant la
salle à est déserte
comme annoncé les avocats ont demandé ce
matin le renvoi des affaires pas d'être
juridictionnelle non plus les avocats
qui protestent contre la réforme des
retraites qui prévoit de les intégrer à
eux aussi au régime universel
les avocats une caisse autonome
c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne coûte rien à la
collectivité elle est auto financé par
l'ensemble des avocats de france et que
cette caisse est excédentaire de 2
milliards cette réforme également a pour
objectif de confisquer ces deux
milliards en plus de l'augmentation des
cotisations que nous payons déjà est
actuellement là nous avons un taux de
13% de minsk à 28 pouces est ce que vous
pensez décemment que quelqu'un peut
accepter ça qu'il soit avocat ou non une
décision dont les conséquences
pourraient à terme impacté le
justiciable
concrètement dans un cadre
passer si l'avocat web
eh ben il va falloir qu'ils trouvent les
sous pour le faire il ya deux manières
de le faire soit ils augmentent encore
ses honoraires
soit il ne le peut pas et à ce moment là
il risque de disparaître
il semble que le gouvernement l'entende
que quand on bloque n'entendre que quand
on durcit la grève les pilotes de ligne
qui ont une capacité de nuisance qui
seront quasiment au même niveau
pour ce qui concerne les caisses
autonomes eux se sont vus déjà accordé
ce qu'ils avaient
demandez les avocats qui rappelle que
leur régime autonome contribue déjà à
hauteur de 100 millions d'euros par an
régime général ici comme dans l'hexagone
la mobilisation était fortement suivi
prévue jusqu'à dimanche elles pourraient
prendre d'autres formes dans le courant
de la semaine